what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
i sold my car so now we're in my
brother's car
before i start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel bring that notification
bell that way you're going to be
notified of my daily videos say hi adam
hello
okay adam
when are you getting married
probably never that's the goal you don't
ever want to get married really
really i know you did legally i lose
everything that i own basically so it's
i don't think
i'll get married yeah i could do a
prenup but
i don't know
there's too many
legal logistics that men has [ __ ] on
so it's like yeah you think i should get
married yeah you guys you guys will win
every time so
should i get a prenup no
take everything
but like what if
well what if i make more money than him
then should i get it freed up probably
do you think no you'll probably still
get more of his assets anyway oh really
so no prenup
no prenup if you're a woman i don't you
see what happened to kelly clarkson no
she should have signed a prenup i'll
tell you that
that's because she's a trumpy husband
didn't she
i don't know yeah
from what i remember you didn't do much
i don't know
what he did would you your wife is a
multi-millionaire
did you know um oh gosh
sometimes adam's driving it's a little
too rough for me
she doesn't like how a box car turns on
corners because box go this way and
cargo this way
okay question
answer um would you date a girl that
weighed more than you
i did at one point
really taylor was heavy
oh i forget that she weighed more than
you but you were like super thin then
yeah it's one 140 at the end of high
school
i graduated 140 pounds
um
yeah i was a little stick
at 6'4
so that doesn't help
so no marriage for you what about kids
yeah i want kids we'll see if that stays
true for the next few years but
how many kids do you want as many as i
could have they're pumping until
as many as i can afford
huh i did not know you wanted like a lot
of kids
you're really good with like little like
boys do you just want boys or do you
want boys i
[Music]
i was wondering because i feel like
whenever there's like a kid at the house
if it's a little boy you guys are like
best friends
it's really cute i like little girls
they bite too much
okay so i think we talked about this
last time we had a car chat
did you know that only 20
of
single men are sexually active according
to like the man manosphere
does that seem true to you or false like
based on like the friends you have
and the people you know
i know a lot of [ __ ]
of your guy friends yeah um i don't know
i mean i could see it
because yeah it doesn't seem sound
astounding
lilo it does sound low
like i feel like 30 to 35 sounds a
little more accurate i would have
guessed 40 to 50 from what i've seen
like 30 to 35 i could say
i i think that's 35 is what i would call
it
35 percent is it that's just 20 suits
low
an awesome
um what qualities do you look for and i
guess you won't get married but allah
um the mother of your kids let's say
well i'll get married in a church i just
won't get married leave okay okay i hate
law the law is not what if you got like
a tax benefit from getting married i'd
consider it the problem is frequently
you don't
frequently i won't at least because i
won't do a lot of things but it's right
there
that
benefit me a lot for taxes
um
because my goal is to be a real estate
king
and being that being with
multiple households
in under the same name doesn't actually
usually help you but if my wife had like
six houses and i had six houses
that would be very beneficial wait so
would she still change her last name
then no
i don't really care about
that would be really
up to mom
mom would be the one that wants that
you know
oh gosh
okay guys we'll continue this after